hey everyone diavalo here and in today's
video i'm going to go over the major
antagonist of tokyo avengers the
absolute mastermind behind probably some
of the most exciting manga chapters that
i've ever read teta kasaki
gokul but before we go over this
insanely amazing character
make sure you hit that subscribe button
to keep up to date with the latest tokyo
avengers content also feel free to leave
a like on the video as well if you do
enjoy my content as it really helps out
with the algorithm and pushes my content
to a bunch of new people but enough of
that let's get into the video
teza kasaki or more well known as just
kisaki is the main antagonist of each
arc so far in tokyo revenges not
including the current running bontine
arc
he is first introduced in chapter two of
the manga as the current leader of toman
along with sano manjiro also better
known as just mikey being 25 in the
present timeline and 13 in the past
makes him one of the youngest characters
in the series being two years younger
than draken and even a year younger than
her crybaby hero takamichi
which makes it all the more impressive
when you realize how mentally superior
he was to every person around him being
able to deduce and challenge someone who
was able to change the future
outsmarting him a variety of times as a
child kisaki was close with hinata
tachibana because they went to the same
cram school which is a specialized
school that changed its students to
achieve specific goals
due to his high intelligence kisaki was
always at the top in terms of grades and
tests as a result
the other children alienated him which
made him extremely isolated
and lonely this lead to him falling into
isolation shutting himself away from the
people he knew which as a result kisaki
developed a cunning and extremely
dangerous personality where he wanted
nothing more than superiority this is
called an inferiority complex
an unrealistic feeling of general
inadequacy caused by
actual or supposed inferiority in one's
sphere
sometimes marked by aggressive behavior
and compensation
this is most likely the reason as why he
only sees people as stepping stones or
his tools to achieve an outcome
but still remember this as it's
extremely evident in his behavior
throughout this series and something
that takamichi never
completely realized almost resulting in
his own death however
while at this cram school hana was the
only one who ever treated him nicely not
acting like she likes him but just
treated him how everyone else should
have i'd say because kisaki hadn't been
treated like this before he slowly
developed a crush
which turned into a lust as he got older
for hinata tachibana
we are first given a taste of kisaki's
insanity when takamichi and naruto go to
meet with the former leader of maui bus
osani who even 12 years after the
incident shook
in fear when was asked the idea of
possibly going against the monolith of a
personality in kisaki
even though takamichi knew going into
this a deal that kisaki was an extremely
dangerous force and the one that killed
a love of his life hinatachibana he
at the time didn't know why and didn't
realize that kisaki would stop at
nothing
and used every person around him
possible to move into a position of
superiority
after the defeat of maui bus and saving
draken and thinking that takamichi
changed the future he returned back to
his future timeline but he's left
shocked when he watches as akun drives
his vehicle up the rear of hina's car
while parked in a parking lot smashing
tachibana's car into the water wall in
front of it and trapping her inside the
burning vehicle
after trying to drag the love of his
life from the burning vehicle and
witnessing her die in front of his eyes
takamiji realized how twisted
and ruthless tetekasaki truly was this
hate that kisaki has for takamichi
stems from two moments from his
childhood that fested into something so
uncontrollable even takamichi with
supernatural abilities stood little
chance at fixing them
the first of these two moments was just
hina and her loving personality being a
kind person to kasaki during cram school
like i've spoken about just before the
second moment is the trigger that ended
up creating the current monster that has
been
kisaki throughout the series and this is
when while he is walking home he sees
that hanada is getting bullied but
instead of going over and helping her he
hides behind a wall due to his lack of
courage
though suddenly takamichi showed up and
tries to fire off the bullies kisaki
noticing the look on hinata's face while
takamichi was doing his best to help her
made him
realise then and there that she had
fallen in love with him this
ended up creating such a deep hatred for
takamachi that he would even kill the
love of his own life just because he
didn't get his way which when you think
about it it's an extremely human quality
of his
this is evident when we see that in a
future timeline and if i'm not wrong i'm
pretty sure it played out in each and
every timeline that takamichi tried to
change
this flash forward i guess you could
call it showed us that kisaki
as an adult asena to the same car park
that heena was killed in bayakun and the
same one that kisaki and takamichi were
also fighting in there he asks tina to
marry him
and proclaims his so-called love for her
but due to takamichi being the love of
heinous life she always refuses
never accepting not in any known
timeline hence why she ended up dying
constantly in every timeline that
takamichi returned to
this is the insanity and the absolute
control that kosaki was able to
manipulate over people
each time takamichi thought one of
kisaki's plans he grew more and more
impatient
trying to achieve his goal during the
tenjiku arc in the final battle between
kisaki and takamichi
it's obvious just how impatient he has
become when he spurs out to takamichi
all of his maniacal plans which started
with killing draken to take the spot as
the number two
and tomen then moved to destroying tomen
and making mikey the headless angel
after that failed his third and final
plan was to instigate
tenjiku into destroying all of tomen he
said that he wanted to control mikey
like a puppet and rule the underworld
his plans were perfect and he knew that
there was only one possible way that
takamichi was ever able to stop him
and somehow he figured that out kasaki
was insane enough and smart enough to
know what takamichi was he somehow
deduced that takamichi was a time leaper
which honestly i think goes to show just
how brilliant kisaki truly was
the fact that his plans were so solid
made takamichi believe that the only
possible way kisaki was also able to
achieve his plans were if he was also a
time leaper but as we now know this was
just a huge
misconception or an assumption on
takamichi's part as he wasn't one at all
or at least he never got to finish the
sentence in which he would have admitted
to being one or
not being one as he was finally killed
when he was hit by the truck the death
of kasaki is something i guess you could
say is a little bit controversial i
don't think i've personally heard anyone
who's actually annoyed with how he ended
up dying but i could definitely see some
people maybe not being too happy with
how he did die
like chukkun is definitely racking up
his kill count rolling through a bunch
of different stories and showing up
killing off a bunch of different people
with a quick drive-by but all chokes
aside i honestly think that he was
giving the kind of death that he really
deserved i'm not going to lie and say
that i personally liked him as a
character or connected with him so i
miss his character
but like takamichi said i hate kasaki to
death i can't help but loathe him there
is no way i'll respect someone like him
he said it himself
he did it all because he loved hina he
also respected me as a rival
that's why i want to face him again i
think this embodies what a majority of
the readers feel like as well like as
soon as he was gone it felt like the
series could have been ended then and
there as the calamity that was
responsible for the future outcomes was
finally dead
it felt like the series had reached its
pinnacle at that moment
maybe the truck was an easy way to get
rid of him as a character but the impact
he had alone was just insane and i think
the truck death was perfect
it was something that i never saw coming
or even expected to happen in that
matter it literally came out of nowhere
and i imagine that's probably exactly
what takamichi thinks as well
he was just as surprised as i was while
reading the chapter and watching a truck
hit him coming out of nowhere while he
was chasing him down something so out of
the blue but completely out of
takamichi's control which is what we
were so used to seeing throughout the
story so far which is why i think the
death was
like kind of perfect because it's just
something that we never really expected
we always expected takamichi to be able
to defeat kisaki
using you know his ability being able to
timely back and fix it that way but as
we finally saw you know there was no
possible outcome where takamichi ever
won against i guess against kisaki
unless he died writing the script
honestly has made my
my thoughts on kisaki a lot like more i
really did enjoy his character a lot
more than i thought he did
but i think this hair explains it like
perfectly and all like from the
beginning i never liked kisaki as a
character
then again i think this is exactly what
ken waiku probably intended to do with
this character and for that i think tita
kasaki
is one of the most amazing antagonists i
have written any manga
i can't even put it into words how
amazing this guy actually is when you
think about it in terms of what
takamichi can do
to kasaki but anyway enough of that i'd
love to know what you all think about
kisaki and whether or not you are
personally happy with the way that he
died if you aren't around here and want
to keep
up to date with the latest tokyo
avengers content then make sure you hit
that subscribe button and also feel free
to leave a like on the video as well
as it really helps out with the
algorithm and pushes my content to a
bunch of new amazing people but anyway
for now it's been a professional
degenerate diavolo and i'll see you all
in a bit bye
[Music]
you